هذه الصور الاولى لهذه الحافله وهي تخرج
طبعا حافله الصليب الاحمر الدولي وهي تخرج
تحمل عدد من الاسرى المحررين
الفلسطينيين تنفيذا
للاتفاق في هذا اليوم اليوم الخامس بعد
تمديد ال غدن ليومين اضافيين اذا هذه صوره
الحافله طبعا تم التقاطها طبعا و نظرا
للظروف ما يقوم به الجانب الاسرائيلي قوات
الامن التي اطلقت الرصاص الحي وكذلك
القنابل المثيله للدموع لتفريق الصحفيين
الذين تحلقوا او كانوا بالقرب من محيط سجن
عوفر لمتابعه هذه اللحظات ولكن تم اطلاق
الرصاص الحي وتفريق الصحفيين وكذلك
المواطنين بالقوه لعدم تغطيه هذا الحدث
نتابع هذه الصور والتعليق عليها مع مره
اخرى معك جيفارا المديري
جيفارا نعم بالفعل عبد القادر الحافله
غادرت بوابه سجن عوفر والان دخلت الى بلده
بيتونيا ترافقها وفق ما نراه هنا من بعيد
على الاقل سيارتين تتبعان للصليب الاحمر
الدولي الان من المتوقع ان تسير الحافله
في شوارع بلده بيتونيا ولكن قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي اقتحمت البلده بالكامل ولا
زالت تطلق القنابل والرصاص بشكل عشوائي
لمنع اي احد من رؤيه الحافله او محاوله
تصويرها ولكن دائما للفلسطيني طرقه في
الوصول لما يريد الحافله الان ستصير كما
ذكرنا من بيتونيا الى احياء في مدينه رام
الله وصولا الى ما يعرف ب المجمع الترويحي
في في حي المصايف في قلب مدينه رام الله
بالطبع هذه الحافله تقل 30 اسيرا وا اسيره
من بين هؤلاء الاسرى كلهم اعتقلوا قبل
السابع من اكتوبر وهذا ما كان ليس متوقعا
لانه وفق مصادر اسرائيليه كان الحديث انه
من اعتقل بعد السابع من اكتوبر اي لن لن
يتم الافراج عنه ولكن واضح ان المقاومه
الفلسطينيه بدات تتمكن من اختراق القواعد
الاسرائيليه التي وضعتها وفق ب